welcome everyone to
um to today's stream our topic is
preparing like a pro I will show you two
games from last year's American Cup
and talk about my preparation and all
the work that went through into it
okay
um so the game that I'm gonna show you
there's two games I played against on
the zutanski she's a player
I have faced many many times before we
have played in many US championships
together we have been teammates she's a
very strong player she's won the US
Women's Championship four times this was
over 2500
uh
like ranked number seven in the world
for women at some point so very good
player
and we have many games from Ria's
Women's Championship we also played one
of the staff matches back in the day
when they were just starting out with
them so I just have a lot of games
against her
so last year I we played in this
tournament called the American Cup we're
going to be playing in this again
this year and she was my first round
opponent so this was a knockout
tournament
it was a mini match of two games and if
the match ended in Thai then there were
tie breaks
so she was my first round opponent and I
lost the first game with the black
pieces so in the second game I was in a
must win situation
so
um
playing against someone I've known for
such a long time it's it's a bit tricky
because we do have a lot of games
against each other
and I know her as a player she knows me
as a player so
it's just interesting to take so many
things into account which I guess for a
lot of players this doesn't happen
because maybe when you're playing and
you're preparing you don't know your
opponent so well but there's a lot of
practical aspects to think about
so first I had to think about what she
will play against me
so after E4 I always play E4 I mean
sometimes actually
uh
in one US championships I played one
Knight F3 against her for the very first
time in my life so maybe she was
expecting that too but she knew that I
was in a Muslim situation so I figured
she would play an opening
where she would feel comfortable in and
also an opening that was quieter and
calmer so
doesn't really enter any complications
and try to keep control of the game and
that's how she likes to play chess in
general she doesn't really seek out
complications on her own in the opening
so I predicted that she would play the
Petrov
hi everyone whoever's joining we're
talking about my games against under
zetanski from last year
um last year's American Cup so this was
a double elimination so I wouldn't get
out of the tournament so you have like
two lives usually elimination tournament
is you lose you get out of here out of
the tournament but I would go into the
elimination bracket where I would get
one more chance
but of course
then you have one live flip right
basically so you do want to keep
advancing and staying in the winners
bracket so the American Cup which is
also coming up so the double elimination
tournament so it's eight players one
played one plays eight so the highest
lower player plays the lowest rated
player
and um so it's a two-game match if it's
a tie then there's tie breaks with
faster time controls and the winner
continues in the winners bracket and the
loser goes to the elimination bracket
and if you lose twice you're out of the
tournament and you still even if you
lose one match There's an opportunity to
win the tournament which is nice
because you can just win the rest of
your matches
but there's also a bonus price if you
win the tournament outright without ever
losing a match so I lost the first game
in some nimzo that she played against me
so I really wanted to win this game but
let's go into tie breaks and against
antiboks also have played some tie
breaks in the US championship for the
title
so I predicted that she would play this
and then I had to decide
what to do against her and what to do
against the Petro which we know is not a
very easy thing to do
and also thinking about
um High pumping cat and also thinking
about how she would prepare against me
and what lines she would choose because
she is trying to avoid
complications
and she just also doesn't want to be out
prepared
and Anna is a player she's
um
she's kind of like me which is a bit of
a time travel addicts but when we play
each other which is both of us spend so
much time in the opening
so I thought maybe that could also give
me an advantage if I cannot prepare her
so I played D4
Bishop did this all of this aligned so
in the Petrov of course there's the 95
move the standard move and D4 is the
other main other option
so I decided to go D4 and this is the
line I have played before Bishop D3
and 95
so I have played this line before and
um I don't know actually what she was
expecting me to play but when I was
looking at the lines of whatever lines I
was Finding they were
there were some Dynamic aspects in the
position
and I thought that would give me some
fighting chances so she played Knight D7
and recently actually hey someone showed
it to me about this opening Explorer on
leeches so I don't know if I don't know
if I can fit it on the stream screen no
it's not part of it maybe I can
um one second guys I'm trying to make
life good for everyone
yeah
just one sec
um
I'm trying all those
so if I do this
yeah I'm just gonna do this I'm gonna
cover my face just for one second
so when talking about preparation and
like different levels of preparation so
someone showed this to me today that
only chest if you go to opening Explorer
so first it shows you
um Master games but it's also possible
to go to
glitches games
um
okay
Okay so
and this is something I would recommend
for players who are lower rated because
when you're preparing I would not
suggest for you to prepare by
looking at like magnuses or hikaru's
games because those games are very high
level so you can actually what you can
do
in a leeches database you can go to
um so when you do this button upon
opening Explorer and table base and then
you can go to leeches database so this
will show games played by leeches
players and then you can
select what kind of average rating
you're looking for and time control so I
think this can be useful so if whatever
bracket you're in you can go up like 200
points 400 points and look at the games
of those players so the or even games of
players of your own level so you can see
what what is likely to happen in your
own games and as opposed to what is
likely to happen in Magnus Carlson game
so I think this is
this is a good way to prepare for
players of lower rated
um low radio players and then you can
also choose the time control of those
players so bullets blades you probably
want to avoid those and maybe wrap it or
okay Blitz can also be okay so you want
to avoid this bullet and Ultra bullet
games and you can select what level
you're looking for and then all set and
all those games come up
and uh you know then you get a kind of
maybe when you get an opening course and
you're studying or you're looking top
level games and then you see certain
games certain moves and then you play
those games never come up
and then you see like certain moves
always come up so this is a way for you
to see
uh which games what most to expect and
what is
um more likely for you
okay so let me transition out of this we
can go back to
here
well
um
I did click the word
there you go
out yeah
okay
uh okay resting first good to see you
too okay so let's go back to this game
so I can show you what I had prepared
and what she played so in this position
she played 97 a very standard move so
Bishop D6 is also a move but let me get
out of here
so after Bishop D7 Castle
and it's also possible to transition to
what we got in the game
but there's also this additional mole of
C4
and you know whenever you're so facing
your opponent's preparation I'm sorry
it's always unpleasant because you know
you're walking into the work that on
someone on my stream sets like they feel
like whenever they walk into preparation
they feel like it's unfair because
like their opponent gets stuff for free
but you know they have prepared and
they've done the work
so in the game she played
um
and
I played Knight C3
so
it's a pretty standard move in this
position but this led her and part of my
preparation was
um
was to try to get her into a position
maybe she doesn't know really well and
make her spend some time
what do I think about a move like Bishop
E5 oh like taking this Knight yeah
taking this Knight is not something we
want to do here
so this is like an interesting position
um argument taking the night
I mean we're happy to get the bishop
pair here because
spawn is not hanging the Knight on e4
hangs so this is we're quite happy about
getting this bishop so there's a funny
looking position because it's so
symmetrical
and um it's kind of like a exchange
French position
but this Knight is being on E5 and E4
like changes things a lot
so I can show you what's going on so 97
and Knight C3 and the point is
uh to put some pressure in the central
Knight and try to change the pawn
structure
so there's several things so now in this
position she actually has to make a
decision
and she has to decide what is what she's
going to do because
potentially right the spawn only four
hangs so there are several ways for
black to react to this in the games so
here she took five minutes and she took
on C3 but there are other options here
too
so one option is to take only five
and then play
so one option is to just not the Knight
is actually hanging here right I want to
take twice
and to go Knight C5 but Knight C5 runs
into this Knight D5 move so this is
quite tactical and that's something you
know when people think petrol not
something they think
because taking is impossible we'll win a
queen
so now she has to give up a pawn and if
we look at this line with the computer
it says like it's okay black has
compensation because of the bishop pair
there's Pawn only five and
a black will trade Queens
Bishop will go to F5 Rooks will come to
the center so like a lot of compensation
it's not a clean Pond that white wins
upon and just wins the game
but
um again making this kind of a decision
over the board it's not so easy
especially in a game where you're trying
to like avoid any kind of conflict and
trying to play as safe as possible
okay
yeah and I think the Practical aspect of
it all and this
um I was actually just talking to
someone about this like when preparing
and when you know maybe you have an
opening file or you look through a game
or do a coach teaches you something and
they explain it to you like everything
looks very logical or if you're
analyzing with an engine all the engine
moves look logical but when you're
playing it the feeling is very different
because you have to make decisions and
especially if you are surprised over the
board you have to make decisions
um and you know you're on your own and
like these decisions aren't as as easy
when you don't have the guidance of a
book or a computer
okay so another option for her was and
this is not something I thought she
would play unless she knew it really
well
because it's not really in her style
it's to play Bishop to B4
castle and take this Pawn
uh so taking only five is not really an
option because of rookie one so like
castles and now we have a tactic of
taking
and winning this bishop back
and this position has been played before
let's see if I can check the database
yeah another one cow do both so pretty
on a high level this position has been
played so now what
um so I wasn't expecting to win the game
out of the opening you know I'm playing
a very formidable player so even if I
get slightly better position it's still
going to be a fight but what I was
looking for is some kind of a dynamic
position with chances if because at this
point I'm taking to I'm willing to take
some risks because it doesn't really
matter if I'm losing one half to half or
two to zero because what's the
difference I'm still getting eliminated
from a bracket so I'm willing to take
risks and she's not really willing to
take risks but what happens here for me
is the structure now changes and now we
enter a more dynamic position with the
opposite colored Bishops and because
it's a middle game opposite color
Bishops give me a chance to attack
opposite color Bishops are great for
attacking
because if I'm able to play like Queen
G3 Bishop H6 or queen G3 Bishop G5 to F6
this bishop is very useless cannot
defend the dark squares so then now
there is a lot of Dynamics in the
position and something I would be very
happy with
um so instead after Castle she decides
to
oops sorry
uh not after Castle after Knight Citrus
it takes takes and Bishop D6
so also again it's possible for her to
take this but again the pawn structure
changes and not something um a post a
poster because of cancel F4 F5 F6 if I
can get it in and um the Dynamics in the
position
so she played Bishop D6 so I have played
this line before and her husband
actually is also a petrol player and
when I was studying these lines I was
also looking at his games and it's kind
of basic my preparation on that too
because you know obviously um
her husband is a very strong Grandmaster
like 2650 so obviously he would help her
prepare especially such an important
game or at least they probably look at
some lines together
so a line that I've played before is
with 97 Bishop D7 Castle
and then there is this bishop H5 move
so this is a double attack so black has
to play F5 in the game I believe my
opponent blundered upon
um so the bishop wants to go to G5 but
now the queen will go to E8 and G6 so
then moving this position is rookie one
threatening Bishop G5 a pretty nasty
threat
and reaching this position
and I believe rookie 3 used to move here
and I've looked at this position before
excuse me I've analyzed it trying to
understand it so
white does have this long-term
compromise structure black can like fix
it with B5 but at the same time black
has a very
King in the long term and it's possible
that this King can come under attack
it's already in this position Rook H3
can become a threat if G6 then it just
weakens the dark squares a bit more
so again some Dynamics in the position
but I thought she probably have seen
this game because this game was in the
database
and it's also possible if I go back and
think about the pet drop
it's also possible that she thought that
I would go for something
and castle in Queen side in this lines
that Bishop out Queen D2 Castle
greenside so it's very possible that she
thought I would go for something like
this
if I think about this from her point of
view
it's a castle
so in this position
um I canceled so again taking on D5
twice is impossible because of the PIN
science that's your castles now my pun
Hank so now I defend it
and um
here she spent like 16 minutes and she
goes she plays C5
um so Black's options are kind of
limited here because I'm of like rookie
doesn't quite work out I can just take
one H7 here
and this can run into some nasty attacks
so not something she wants to allow so
like at that C5 was a pretty logical
move and move that is
quite easy to play but maybe she didn't
she wasn't very familiar with this
position sometimes when you walk into
prep you know you just start seeing
ghosts because you just feel so
uncomfortable
and my threat in this position is to
play Queen F3 go after this Pawn let's
develop my pieces
and she has to think about how she's
going to finish her development so maybe
she was also considering of taking
taking something like this but again I
don't mind this kind of a dynamic I can
try to play a four here also Bishop A3
might be a move here so again going for
this opposite color Bishop position it's
not something I mind
and taking this this is a possibility
but I don't think
actually it's interesting
yeah I don't think something she wants
to do
and again she can come under very strong
attack here
so she plays C5
so this all has been played before
Queen F3 and again
she spend a lot of time here and she
made a mistake which is understandable
to me because at this point so I'm
playing very fast which puts a lot of
a lot of pressure on her because you
know she knows I'm prepared and she's
probably like not feeling very confident
and I think it's because of the
tournament structure situation the back
of her mind is like don't take risks
keep things calm like don't make
complicate things you're playing for a
draw and you know when you're playing
for a result it's a bit cliche but it
does make things a bit complicated
going for the opposite color Bishops in
Mill game is a new idea no
um yeah I I know like this is what's
opposite color Bishops are known for for
a drawn end game but as soon as you
start adding pieces like the nature of
the position completely changes if you
have opposite color vision position and
then you add two pairs of Rooks it just
completely changes the position and with
[Music]
um
and with more pieces on the board
especially if you're creating an attack
it just can be completely devastating
because if I like um like if something
like this happens right if I somehow my
Bishop gets to Bishop G5 Bishop F6 is C8
Bishop is just completely useless
so this is a dynamic that she had to
think about and here I'm playing very
quickly so I go Queen F3
and now her D5 Pawn is under attack so
the only move for her was to play
C4 to keep the position level and
something that's been played before but
I understand how C4 is a difficult move
to play over the board
um
because it's just so communal when you
play a move like C4 then this D5 Pawn
becomes forever weak and
and there is no taking back the C4 move
it fixes the pun structure so again like
middle moves when you're in this mindset
where you want to make a draw
um are not you know like top of your
list so she plays a move that makes more
sense and she spends another eight
minutes
now Bishop G5 but now Bishop G5 but now
again her um Central starts to hang
and now she has to think about once
again I want to take
and take and again she has to think
about what how to defend the spawn
and that's such an easy thing to do
because also now my Rook can go to D1
and something like C4 and this pin is
actually quite can be quite nasty for
her because how does she get out of this
pin
yeah when you have opposite color
Bishops you if you're attacking you play
on the squares of the color of your
Bishop because your opponent's Bishop
cannot defend them
so Bishop G5 C4
now Bishop F5 and
Bishop B7
um so I have my notes from after I
analyze this game so yeah so in this
position I was just thinking about
Bishop C8 which is kind of silly because
I'm exchanging her useless Bishop for my
good one so I think I have other options
I think taking on F6 Knight G4 was
um
was an option rugby one is also an
option and just like letting her take on
F5
and there's also the other side of
getting your prep in which is something
that has happened to me
um like this problem that I don't know
how much of a problem it is maybe it's
just me
but when I've had games where I got a
lot of prepping and I remember 2019 us
Championship my first round game
a lot of prep like 20 minutes prep
I got a winning position
it was like plus two with the engine
up on time anything I could have wanted
and then I started to misplay
and then the position just slipped out
of my hands and then it was no longer
winning but because I was just um well
first of all I got very emotional
because
you know I've done all this work I come
with preparation and I I haven't
prepared her
it was almost like hotter she not lose
this game and I ended up losing the game
because I just couldn't come to terms
with the fact that just because my prep
was better just because you know I had a
good position out of the opening doesn't
mean that I just have to win the game
easily it's still possible to make
mistakes later
yeah so in this game too I also got
everything that I wanted I knew my
position is good and now I'm like okay
so how am I gonna try to improve my
position even more
so when I so when I started kind of at
some point I did misplay the position a
little bit and I feel like um the
advantage slipped out of my hand I
started getting like very emotional and
very frustrated because I was just like
very upset with myself because I you
know especially against a player like
Anna that I know if I I'll prepare her
like I know how she's going to feel and
you know I can get a huge time Advantage
so when and then I started spending more
time too and our time became more equal
like I started getting very frustrated
um how do you evaluate the edginess or
the sharpness of a position even with
the pension um well you look through the
engine moves and then you see if so like
when the engine gives you an evaluation
of moves like you can see like several
moves right so if there's only one line
that's plus two and the second line is
like minus seven then you know you have
to find different kind of
um you have to find like only moves
there are different levels of plus one
or plus two if there's a plus two that
requires you to find like seven only
moves in a row that's like a completely
different than when an engine gives you
one move that's plus two another move
that's what 1.7 another one that's like
1.3 then you're like okay no matter what
I play my advantage is there maybe it's
a matter of like how big it Advantage I
have in a position
um
I'm not sure that the light Square
Bishop is a bit better than the dark
Square One
um maybe when I was talking about the
French positions yesterday
okay so I took on C8 and I took on F6 so
I did this position when I was playing
it actually here I'm still quite happy
because
and this bishop F6 move is also
an interesting
decision for me because
it's we don't often see a trade
overnight for a bishop a bishop for a
night usually it's the other way around
but when I look at this position again
she played the C4 move that maybe she
didn't want to play but now all I see is
this D5 weakness right and my Bishop
cannot attack it but my knight can her
Knight can defend it but her Bishop
can't so once I trade this I was like oh
once I come and start attacking this pun
like how is she gonna defend it so her
best hope is to trade her Bishop for the
Knight
so I go Knight G4
um
so during the game I remember I was
thinking Rook a B1 and it's very
interesting when you're considering
what are you thinking during the game
and then sometimes during the game
everything is just like so dramatic
everything is just like so complicated
and you can make a decision then after
the game you just look at it with like
completely different point and you're
like oh my God like why and I play this
this is so simple of course like
so I was thinking of this line Queen A5
takes Nash's threatening mate G3 takes
the spawn too and during the game I was
like okay like Queen G6 maybe it's not
so simple
I don't remember what the engine was
giving me I think well this engine gives
me like a huge Plus
but yeah I mean I wasn't so sure during
the game about
all this and you know like I've been
talking about like the psychological
aspect of her thinking like she wants to
make a draw she doesn't want to make
things complicated but from my point of
view like I have to win this game right
for her if she loses at least we've got
two tie breaks for me I'm playing for
one result for her bond result is great
to result at least she gets another
chance so like for me I also have to
think about okay if I trade too many
pieces maybe position be constantly to
drive like I still want to keep some
tension in the game
uh so I played Knight G4
Queen D7
and here I remember during the game I
was considering Rook B5 and I spent so
much time on this and I was just like oh
my it was funny because I remember very
distinctly during the game I was like
okay there's no rookie one
because then F6 said in the end and then
I was like oh my gosh it's just gonna
take on B5 and it's just game over
uh the tournament that I'm talking about
is American Cup which is a double
elimination so she was my first round
opponent I lost the first game so the
second game I had I was in a Muslim
situation not to lose the match so this
is why there is so much that goes into
you know this kind of decisions here
because if it was any kind of a
tournament game then you know
you make decisions but this Muslim
situation is kind of tough
okay so I played G3
I'll start doubling my Rooks
so um I mean I'm still quite happy here
but now she's just holding the position
and I'll also compromised my Pawn
structure in the long term so it's not
like
um you know like I got everything I
wanted in the world with nothing to give
um you know and gave up nothing
and I wasn't sure how to keep my
advantage going and I think at this
point like I was no longer really ahead
on the clock so this was also getting a
bit frustrating for me
so now we just shuffle a bit so yeah she
would love to trade this
so
so I what I missed here I missed
something critical so here negative six
yeah I missed something simple here
because I remember calculating this and
I thought there's G6 but I missed that
here takes takes and then there's 97.
yeah which is very unfortunate wait I
also have a line with oh yeah
another thing I didn't seem
which is rookie six
what
yeah like all kinds of lines that I
missed here I've analyzed this after
with the engine
and queen G4 rookie two this is the line
takes takes and rookie seven just
cutting this communication between the
queen and the bishop
I didn't see it during the game
how to calm your nurse during the game
yeah I mean that's tough to do you just
I think
um
sometimes what I do is just
especially in this tournament I had to
do it several times including in this
game because this game just got a bit
out of control
so let me see what happened in the game
so this game was actually very long so I
don't think there's a point for us to
look through all of it
and yeah eventually
um I feel like I kind of let a lot of my
advantage sleep and then we entered this
position and one thing I think I did
really well in this game is just keep
games going for a long time and you know
the longer you keep the game going
it's a bit double-edged because both of
it gives you a lot of chances to win but
also gives you chances to make mistakes
so if you ever find yourself in a very
bad position it's very good idea to like
if you can
kind of stop the damage and don't make
any more huge mistakes where it ends the
game but instead just keep the game
going
make moves you know force your opponent
to make decisions it will give you a lot
of chances
so I thought okay at least this position
I kind of
let a lot of my advantage go but now she
has this E6 backwards pawn and at least
uh you know we can play for a very long
time and I actually did this twice in
this tournament when
uh I was again in a Muslim situation
against the player and she just found a
way to trade every piece and I was again
getting so frustrated I was like how is
she finding she's like hunting all my
pieces and then at the end I think it
was like Queen either two Rooks versus
queen turoks or queen Rogue against
Queen rook and I just like I was just
like okay I'm just gonna make moves at
some point like mentally I was ready to
make it a job and I was like no and just
kept making moves kept going kept going
at some point she blundered again this
nerves of you know wanting a result so
bad
yeah so at this point I'm just playing
against this um
the structure and a good thing for me is
I have two ideas so this E6 Pawn is um
so weak and also if I go H5 I can also
weaken her King
so I will just play through the game
because
um we're far
Beyond of what we're talking about here
and
so we get to this position I'm trying to
keep pieces on
and then at some point I have to start
making some commitments because
one weakness is not enough
so we're just shuffling back and forth
and then
at some point
um
yeah she made a mistake here
she took this Pawn but now my king ran
to safety
uh this moment I remember in the game
was funny because I could have taken a
rook but then I calculated checkmates
instead of taking a rook I played 26 and
um
I'm checkmating her
which I was quite happy about
yeah so this was
um
very up and down game
so I started off really well for me I
you know I had my prep I got my prepping
I was up on time I had a good position
everything you can ever trim off to get
out of the opening but then
you know I had to start playing moves on
my own which is a difficult part and the
advantage slipped away from me but I
think my position was always good so it
was always a two result game obviously
you're gonna win or it was going to be a
draw it was never I was never in danger
in this game which is a very nice
feeling to have that you know your
opponent never really had a chance to
win the game
and um so like what uh When I Was
preparing against this game mainly you
know thinking about the kind of
positions my opponent will want that
kind of position she doesn't like
because so she's a player I know very
well and this is a very high stakes game
of course high stakes for both of us
so I think choosing this line worked out
really well for me
and so she lost this game and then we
went into tie break so tyrex I'm gonna
say it was Game 25 plus five it was not
a very long um we're playing rapid but
so there were like two kinds of Rapid I
think it was Game 25 plus five and then
game tens well actually this might have
been game 10 because this was after this
round okay this was a year ago so I
remember that clearly
so I think then we go to tiebrex because
one of us has to get knocked out and go
into elimination bracket so because of
the pairing sound white again so I was
like okay great
I'm white again if she plays the Petra
I'm just gonna repeat this line and let
her figure out what to do and also we
played this game there isn't a lot of
time to prepare so I was like what is
she gonna find against this line this is
probably gonna play something else
and since I had won this game now like
the feeling is different right it's
always like when you go into a tie break
we come from different mindsets because
she won the first game and she had the
chance to clinch and she lost whereas I
lost the first game and I won a must win
game so they gave me a huge boost
because I'm coming off a victory and you
know like winning this clutch game so
that's a big confidence boost for me
where else for her it's like the
opposite it's like oh like I messed up
in this really important game and now I
have to go play a tie break
um so so now we we repeat the Slime so
she decided to repeat and I'm like great
so we played the same line again 97
Knight C3 take Stakes so this time we're
both playing fast
C4 Bishop F5
so now this time yeah so now this in the
last game she played um
Knight F6 this game she goes C4
immediately and on it um now she takes
and Bishop here
and now we don't enter those opposite
color Bishop's position anymore because
now she's forcing a trade of the bishop
and of course this is a very convenient
trade for her as we happen in the game
even though I didn't have seconds yet
because her Bishop hasn't moved and my
Bishop has already moved a few times so
it's very convenient for her to develop
a bishop and immediately Trade It
so I I here I took and Bishop B3
and here my mindset is also different
because
um so I'm playing with the white pieces
so a win would be really nice because
next game is black so I think in this um
to round matches it's kind of nice to
have black in the first run because no
matter what happens at least you can try
to win the next game with white
so I was like okay it'd be really nice
if I win if not then
playing Black so maybe I can try to
fight for a drum
or okay anything can happen right this
because this was our second game in the
day and we had one more game to play so
it was like playing three games in one
day it's pretty tough and if everything
ends in a draw then we just keep either
we keep playing or we it was already in
Armageddon
so she played rookie eight
takes takes on Rook D1
and
um like she improved on what she did
before but I think again she found
um you know you can improve on your
opening but you cannot
like change your playing style or your
preferences so quickly
I mean it goes for her and of course it
goes for me too it's not like
I prepare a line and I become a
different type of player I still have
things that I like in chess in a
position that I gravitate towards so
even in this position I thought okay
there's some Dynamics so I heard what
she did here with Rook A5 this was a
very good way for her to play because
this Rook here is very annoying and the
thing is if we enter any kind of end
game or like if I lose this A2 Pawn it's
very dangerous because this Pawn just
runs whereas if she loses this D5 Pawn
like she loses this backwards Pawn
that's kind of useless so it's you know
this is a pretty good trade out for her
but I thought there's still a lot of
Dynamics in the position because if I
take on D5 I get the D file and because
of this Pawn majority
um I still have some attacking chances
so I thought maybe I can still attack
so I went H3 natural move
like kind of a nothing move creating a
love for my king
and Rook D4 so Rook D4 is um
uh I think this was an inaccurate move
actually because it runs into F6 but
okay this is a rapid game
but my idea is both to go Rook D1 and
try to get this D file and also swing
The Rook to this side and try to create
an attack
so she went to Queen E6
um
and rookie two
and here is a bit of a trap because F6
is not a move
because I have this in intermezza F7
instead she plays H6
and queen E3
oh yeah queenity right here it was a
mistake because now she has F6 here
so she's happy to trade pieces because
any kind of end game
I I think black has very good chances
because it takes on A2 and I have to
deal with this distant past Pawn on A7
and this is like super annoying for me
so not something we want to do
but you didn't play F6 she played Rook
A2
and I just you know parted ways with
this Pawn I was like you can have this
pawn and now I'm starting to push on
this side now I want to play Queen F3 F5
and if I get all this moves in then uh
hurricane can actually become quite
uncomfortable
so she brought this back and queen F3
so now I just want to play a five
if I pass the move if I play a five this
is actually becoming very uncomfortable
so the queen goes somewhere so Rook G4
is a possible F6 immediately and uh here
she might actually just be getting mated
so instead she plays
excuse me
she plays F5 and now I switch gears so
now I want to take her deep Palm but
what has happened with F5 now
I have a past one and I have a protected
pass Pawn so at least I have achieved
something and yeah I understand that she
has this distant past pan but we still
have some pieces on the board and also
this D6 Square so the row can go on D6
kick this queen away so I still feel
like I have attacking chances here
I took
um because of the pin so I would be very
happy about this kind of trade
so she checked so now I have to block
because she protected The Rook
so Rook C5
now my pan is hanging so now I go after
her Pawn
and I take on D5
um
so this is actually a very big moment in
the game and
you know there are several big moments
in the game and the key is to catch
those moments and so at this point the
way that I played like my Pawn is
already hanging so and it's hanging with
a temple so she takes on Citra then
kicks away my queen this is night
um
she did have Rook C3 but she didn't want
to give up this pun this would have been
very dangerous to give up this kingside
Pawn
because again now I'm gonna move go F5
F6 D5 is hanging I think this is very
dangerous for her
like this F5 pan is actually quite
important
so she decides to hang on to this pun
but next month she wants to take on C3
and I took on D5 and during the game I
was actually quite concerned or I wasn't
at least sure
what happens if
um she goes for this end game because
okay I have won a pawn but I have this
double pawns so she can play Rook C8 try
to take this Pawns and she has this
distant past pawn and she can't stop my
pond very quickly
so I wonder what this engine thinks
so during the game I just um I was like
I don't know if she goes for this I
don't know if this is a winnable end
game for me
but instead and like from her point of
view I also see this like why this is a
difficult decision to make especially
because we just played a game where
I was on the better side of it the whole
game right and she was basically
suffering for like three four hours it
was just suffering for her very
eventually she blundered a lot so you
know we're both tired but like I'm on
the good side of all of this good side
of the tired good side of the emotional
uh excitement so I just have of them
positives of this match so far
so I can see why she didn't want to take
on D5 because now she has to play
another end game where she's you know
fighting for a draw
so instead she took on C3 which I think
is very logical and
and she probably has said this because I
didn't and she took on C2 and this was a
very unpleasant moment for me because I
think I blundered this but I was like
okay
um but it yeah I've seen my notes so I
said I blundered this but I was ahead on
the clock here and in a rapid game this
makes a huge difference and the whole
point is if I take she takes on D5
so instead I played Rook D6 so of course
two trades and queen E4
which is kind of annoying for me because
she's tickling my pun which means my
queen cannot be active but even in this
position I thought it's so unclear
because uh her Kink feels weaker than
mine I can go Rook D7 my past Pawn is
more annoying than hers
and I think the evaluation of this
position with the computer is just
um pretty level but obviously when
someone asked me how to evaluate the
edginess of the position when you give
an evaluation so okay if the computer
says it's equal here but you know
there's attacking aspects as this Pawn
might be queening so there's a lot of
things for her to deal with
but of course I'm also down upon so I
might just lose it down upon
so I check and I grab my palm back
Rook C7 now at least her Rook is free
and I think her King is actually safer
on H7 so this is a nicer configuration
for her so I come back with my coin
and now I start pushing my pun
ah yeah so Queen C6 this was some kind
of a computer analysis
but to me like this looks so scary
because this king is just so much weaker
it only has these two Pawns
okay you play Move Like G6 as king is
just so weak and then you go back
rookie four I tried to like check you on
the background
just um
I don't know I I think if anyone's going
to lose this most likely black because
at worst white can trade into some kind
of a rook end game and it's a the puns
are equal but for black it's possible
this King just gets in trouble
but I believe around here somewhere she
makes a huge mistake yeah and the
nauseous tries to Chase my queen away so
she starts like harassing my queen
and here she just completely collapsed
and given everything that happened in
this last game and this game I can't
totally understand this
because now this Pawn is also hanging
and like if she goes Rook C5 I will just
take it so and she played Queenie too
trying to take this Pawn I think she was
thinking you know you go here I take
your Pawn but of course it just hangs a
F5 pawn and here
um I think she flagged if I remember
correctly but okay after Rook B7
there is no salvaging this position
so this preparation actually basically
won two games for me so the first game
not what I was expecting because like I
knew the line where she played correctly
in this game oh thank you
racing Forest I was quite happy about
this game too
like in this line when where are we so I
knew like C4 is the move so when she
doesn't play C4 I just know my position
is good right that's the good thing
about preparation there's you're playing
a forcing line and your opponent plays
something else you're like okay they did
something wrong so
I know my position is good so I got the
good position I don't like I didn't
really handle it in the best way it
still became a fight she still had some
chances to you know make a drop even
though I was like always on the good
side of this game that game I believe
and here she improved but I think
because of the previous game and because
I did spend a lot of time preparing
those lines and I got quite lucky
because she didn't she improvised on
what she played in the first game but
she didn't play completely different
because if she played completely
different than both of us would be out
of preparation but because by playing
this line she still played something
that I had prepared for because I just
assumed that you know it's possible she
will go for this line
because it is the best line
and if not then great and like her and
because she misplayed it in the first
game and then improved on the first game
by playing the correct line I was still
in my element I was still playing fast
and I knew the idea as well so I felt
quite comfortable so this was um
quite a good preparation even though you
know not like this position leads to
anything good just leads to some kind of
a dynamic game but when we're preparing
and we're thinking of which line to
choose it's not about
it's not very common way to get a
position where you just first of all
winning got right not coming at a
certain level doesn't really happen
unless you get lucky or even getting a
big Advantage it's just a matter of
finding a position
you're comfortable with and also
makes your opponent uncomfortable of
course it's always possible to play some
kind of a risky line and say like what
other chances my opponent has looked at
this line in the past I don't know two
years or whatever
five months so that's always the
possibility but um
you know like the two things in finding
position you're comfortable in and
making your opponent uncomfortable so
those are when preparing for again
someone specific this has like the main
things to keep in mind
so there's a good chance that I might be
playing again this year so maybe maybe
she will see this video so we can avoid
this line altogether
I don't think we're in the same I don't
know the pairings yet but I don't think
we're going to be in the same bracket at
all until maybe we can meet in the
finals
but um
yeah so this was um I have some examples
of preparation that didn't go my well at
all where I walked into preparation I
can be quite stubborn but this one I am
quite happy about
so we don't have a stream tomorrow but
on Saturday there is a signal so
hopefully you guys will stop by
all right thanks everyone
and I'll see you on Saturday